If you let it, this world will take you.
If you do not persevere and take risks to
pursue what you want to do and instead, submit
to fears and uncertainties, this world will
deprive you of your life and decide what to
do with you, for you.
It will put you in the passenger seat and
find someone or something else more capable
of doing the driving.
In life, there is no risk in risking it all
to become who you want to be and to do what
you want to do.
The only real risk is if you never take it.
Because if you do not face the fears, challenges,
and potential setbacks on the path of doing
what you want and achieving what you believe
in, life will be nothing more than doing things
you don’t want to do for things that you
don’t believe in.
You will feel sedentary in a life that requires
movement.
You will feel helpless in a life that requires
a sense of self-control.
You will feel as though you not only failed
to reach your true purpose and ideals, but
that you failed to even try.
You will feel weak and incomplete, and you
will die without knowing what you could have
done and who you ultimately could have been.
And with that, you would already be as good
as dead long before death arrives.
In the case of striving towards your goals,
beliefs, passions, and legacy, what are you
really risking by taking risks?
If you are not yet excited or fulfilled by
your life, than you essentially have nothing
to lose.
Your sense of life is incomplete.
Your sense of purpose is unfilled.
You have no rational choice other than to
do anything and everything to fill it.
Certainly, finding and filling ones’ sense
of purpose and passion is no easy task.
It can be painstaking and grueling to find
out what that even is, let alone working towards
it and achieving success in it.
But without this piece, everything else in
life will become poisoned by the toxicity
of feeling unfulfilled or inadequate.
Risk it all to make your life what you hope
it can be.
To find a sense of meaningfulness and control
over how you spend your time and how you impact
this world.
To love what you work for and to work for
what you love.
Because the upside of taking risks for this
is everything and the downside is most likely
just where
you are now.